this is the smiler al hamdulillah Salam
alaikum peace be with you this is a
greeting of all the messages of God
including Abraham Noah Moses Jesus
Christ and the last and final messenger
sent to mankind the problem Hamid peace
be upon they all greeted their followers
and we're greeting you with the same
greeting peace be unto you we're going
to be talking continuing talking to
Sheikh Ibrahim sedan we covered this
topic for the test of life it's such a
vast topic we're going to dwell into it
some more the tests of life from the
womb to the tomb is a big test in
between we want to pass the test because
we want Jenna we want paradise forever
ever and we want to avoid the Hellfire
we don't want to spend a second there so
we want to pass the test sit tight when
we talking about the tests of life when
we come back here on the detail right
back this is the thing
this is the this is the things this is
the peace be unto you Salaam alaikum
shake when I open the show did I lie I
mean we know that as Muslims ones who
have submitted entirely to the One God
we know that Jesus was a Muslim Abraham
was so much they were on Muslims am i
lying that's good and they greeted their
followers with this greeting of peace
yes Salaam alaikum Salaam or lake in
Hebrew so I mean we're do we're just
continuing the legacy our ways right
it's the same thing and that's why when
we say Islam we don't say just word of
means of nothing does not refer to a
tribe or anything it means to the state
that a human being should be in that is
to submit yourself to the Creator that
engineer and who would reject this
that's why we all have to submit
themselves to the one that you ate it
and you hear piece being associated with
Islam I mean do are we people who want
peace of course actually the word Islam
it means submission does not mean peace
but it has the same root as far as the
word with the words peace so that means
you would get the real peace if you
submit yourself to the Creator so is it
safe to say peace acquired by submitting
your will yourself to the creator of the
heavens honor of the one guy right and
when we say Salaam Salaam alaikum we are
making dua supplication to the most high
that when I say said I'm to you that are
making direct to Allah that you are safe
from all harm in this life and in the
hereafter and this is what every human
being wants so we want good we want we
want and I think the best gift that we
can give to humanity is this now that's
right better than the Ferrari
rolls-royce big house is this message of
of calling one to have peace with their
crater because then you can truly have
peace with yourself in the rest of
humanity is natural and that what stays
forever
it is connected in this life with the
hereafter not something that is a metal
that will vanish after some time exactly
exactly and we're talking about in this
episode people go to the Dean show calm
you have your own section there we've
done over the years we've done many
shows all praise and thanks Estelle a
law was given us life we're here again
and seems like yesterday but hamdullah
we're here today and we're talking about
the tests of life so in the last program
that we covered we talked about that the
Creator some verses that we mentioned
and you commented on is that a law says
in the noble glorious quran that i have
not created life and death except a test
which of you are best in action and then
you know does man think that he'll be
left alone i just saying I believe it
he'll not be tested and you also talked
about will test you with fear hunger
does that any other can you kind of
recap in and these verses and comment on
them and before I ask you some more
questions that this life this whole
entire life is an anything in it is for
a great wisdom and that's why people
need to be tested for them to be shown
who is the truth for once and who is not
truthful and the qualities of the human
beings and the goodness in the human
beings a lost panel tyla made it in such
a way that we have to be faced with some
tests so that the real qualities of the
human being will be shown and the
attributes of Allah that is the most
wise that is the most forgiver will be
in place and practice when people are
enduring patience and even in
relationships and so on so it's
basically any would we say and the
action we do any state that we are in
any relationship it's basically a test
this is not necessarily something bad
but can be something even good and but
we will be tested with what is good and
what has been now when you go from you
know our brother want gradually he just
got his master's degree you know I
brother Imam he got tested right he has
to read a lot of books and he had to you
know study a lot masha'Allah and you
know people to go from from one degree
to the next you know you got to get
tested isn't it true that's not a bad
thing it's a good thing because all that
study and all that commitment you know
at the end it pays off and you know what
amazing which is another act of worship
to be constantly done the things that
people do physically and the things are
physical signs of Allah on the face of
it it has to be related to what Allah
wants from us religiously so you can do
that that's right haha people are tested
people they love justice before they
love mercy you know people like to be
forgiven if they do something bad and
all of these meanings is the same thing
when it comes to our relationship with
the creator of the heavens and the earth
he is testing us because we have to be
tested to see who's deserves to be a
doctor who's not right people have just
claimed I'm a doctor sure go ahead and
do the surgery no people have to be
proven to be up to that level so if a
person say i believe i love allah the
most perfect love i I follow the
messenger salallahu ism it's all words
how truthful the person is with the
words that we say then here's the test
that's why I lost panel Todd I gave a
very important and heavy test call in
kuntum to hey Boone allaha veteran Aviva
koala say o Muhammad selasa if you claim
that you love Allah and I believe every
human being all the viewers nobody would
say I don't like a lot everybody love
Allah love the creator of the heavens
and ears say if you truly saying that
you love Allah then follow the Prophet
SAW Denarius Allah Allah would love you
because he sent him so how can he sent
him and you don't follow him that means
you're not truly loving the creator of
the heavens and the earth so the
truthfulness is for a person's words to
be according to our actions our deeds
out of our hearts everything in the same
stamp very in conformity with one
another now it's interesting I like what
you said we can relate it back to our
daily dealings and aren't we testing
each other here and there you know the
man is tested his wife Dwight's testing
you know the husband and the kids you
know to see like you know two separate
to see does he really love me the she
really loved me so you have person do
certain things and you know if they get
through these even the the worker for
the boss and only after so many years do
you develop the trust do you develop
some kind of relationship
they're all these tests right is that
fair to say it's it's fair to say and
that's what it doesn't have to be that
people would test one another in such a
way waiting and anticipating for another
but people are test for one another they
bring out from your heart what you are
truly is so for example if you are
someone that gets angry quickly you
might not do that with me sitting here
because you don't see me much but that
quality in you if it's dead it would be
very clear with your wife because you
live with her she's easy all the time so
there's no formalities anymore so the
real qualities will come this is by self
is a test so the wife becomes a test for
her husband because the real qualities
the bad qualities will come out and they
need to work on himself to control
himself and to be a righteous person and
so on the same thing from the other side
and so on let's take a break we'll be
right back with more here Indonesia no
problem you can take my daughter to
dinner you and my daughter and me did
you ever tell you something it's natural
that's the idea I created it and he
created us to have a good time you
should have a good time one without
wives though Islam is the fastest
growing religion in the world and most
of the converts are women not men they
see that the rules of Islam instead of
constraining it the rules set them free
one
back here on the Dean show we're talking
about the tests of life handling these
tests that come and you mentioned one ID
from the last and final mission said the
man kind of problem Hamid peace be upon
him said at that moment patience is at
the time of calamity right right and
you'll see for instance is this the
right way the wrong way you know there
was a story one individual was talking
about I he went to the hospital to visit
someone there and two individuals on
different floors and the one individual
is very sick and you went to visit him
how you doing he was kind of like
anticipating how when he walks in he was
feel very sad sad at what happened to
the person so you know you're kind of
like how do I you know approach the
person you know you know them I going to
say the right things but as soon as he
came in the person was sick but he was
excited he said hamdulillah come in he
was praising God everything was good and
it worked out all right he went to see
someone else and the other person was
like complaining why would god I've been
worshipping God all these years why did
he put this on me why is this happening
to me we could we comment on these which
is the right way which is the wrong ways
the one that complains is basically does
not know God with his names and
attributes because God is the most twice
and this life is nothing but 20 30 50 60
years and it's all over and God wants
from us to do certain acts of worship
that would never be there as we
mentioned before unless the person would
face some form of calamities and
hardship and so on because of the
goodness that comes as a result of that
the other person of course you see the
amend this is the result or the reward
to him as a result of his sincerity
before he was sick and we have to watch
this a person if he said that I was been
worshipping Allah and so on he was not
worshipping Allah spano tada in the
correct way he was not sincerely
worshipping among the correct way if he
was sincerely doing that he would
definitely be rewarded at times of
calamity that he would have the proper
attitude I remember a brother lost
planet Allah have mercy on him he was
amazing
he was someone that was totally
paralyzed except his face and the
muscles of his fee see he has to have
somebody to feed him this person was
full of life and Joey anytime you feel
upset you go to him you asked him how
are you brother he would see al
hamdulillah he's always so happy that
he's a Muslim the the concept that he is
that a la spina Tyler saved him and made
him a Muslim for him that covered
everything and all calamities and pain
in his life he would have cancers and
pains and so on and so forth but he
would never quit saying hamdulillah and
I have a little story with his brother
yes but I don't know here we have the
time yeah go ahead what time I was he
all come to the message it cold weather
doesn't matter he comes to the message
and he left one time after esha pray and
the lecture was finished and I went home
and it was in a place where i usually
don't leave the house after esha tree
nighttime but I had to go that one
particular night because a child needed
the medicine and I went and I drove my
car going to a 24 hours pharmacy and I
see this brother this is like something
like 2-3 hours after isha prayer in the
wintertime in the cold and the snow and
he is on the sidewalk with his
wheelchair sitting like this and not
moving and the street is totally empty
and it's not a good neighborhood i
stopped the car and i was i was worried
about him and went to him i said brother
Harry for how are you he said
alhamdulillah he did not say where are
you I'm and he was not panic in anything
said hamdullah the bounty of Allah Islam
is so great that this is the best bounty
that I have he's so relaxed and so much
tranquility and peace in such a
situation where I'm not sure if I was in
his state what would I do so it was so
amazing that God sent me basically to go
out to take the brother home because he
said the battery one that all his
imaginary in the wheelchair oh so that's
why he when it happened he just said
they're waiting this brother he would
constantly have people embracing Islam
when they see his character he would
give direct down to people and when
people see this he's not someone that is
given up on life wants to commit
suicide he is full of hope and joy and
he's happy witnessing the wisdom of
Allah and people die and when a person
when he died things finished things will
finish yes so why would a person panic
so much in the face of earth when we
need to take advantage of the time that
we live in and see the wisdom of Allah
and everything that happens to there's
also another brother that we did a show
with is he's a young man he's also from
his he's in a wheelchair and his name is
son L like you shouldn't shout out the
Sun oh he's also very excited when you
see him you know he's going through a
lot and people can go to these show to
CSUN else story and he's kind of in a
similar situation in the wheelchair but
he's very buoyant when you see him you
know he's smiling and very cheerful but
you might see someone opposite who had
let's say 10 million dollars and you
hear about someone like this and then in
the stocks market he lost let's say half
of it five million he still got five
minute left this other person in the
wheelchair he don't even have anything
close to that money but he still thank
God he still contempt he's still
satisfied this person just lost five mil
has another five minute but he jumps out
the window what's going on here what's
going on here it shows the mercy of
Allah that happiness is never buy
something external from outside
happiness is within and that's the
justice of the creator of the heavens
and earth doesn't matter if you're full
of rich you can be the most happiest
person on the face of earth if you are
someone that is following the orders of
Allah vinyl tile and that's why it's in
here and this is the justice of Allah it
does not go by how much wealth a person
is so this is a great wisdom and
something that again and again we as
human beings people are not thinking
people are not analyzing what's
happening people are just busy with fun
work wealth this and that and they're
not stopping and thinking why this has
happened in a good way what's what Allah
the most high wants from me what are we
going to to face what is this life is
all about we as Muslims since Islam
respect the mind of the human being if
we can get
a person to think this is the best thing
that you can wear you can have think
what's the purpose of our life what is
the the creator of the heavens and the
earth and his relationship with the
creation what is the most noble thing to
live for if we think like this and
what's coming ahead I think with
sincerity and truthfulness people would
find the truth in the religion of Allah
this is that fits the nature of the
human being that there is all answers to
our questions the happiest individual on
the face of earth is someone that
submits himself to the most wise the
most high a lost paradise so the point
is if you want to be happy on the face
of earth and beer after the only way is
to submit yourself to the creator of the
heavens in here now can this also these
tests and trials if you pass it do you
get like in school where you get raised
in rank in your degree if you pass it
with patience and perseverance are you
having a bigger level in Paradise also
of course not just a bigger level its
rewards without an account without
limits you know things in the Quran and
the Sunnah for example if you do an act
of worship you'll get ten rewards you
will get this reward so on but when it
comes to some to patients that he would
mentioned in the Quran in my office
lobby Luna agile humbly he said which
means the sabi ruled the patient ones
they would be given in full their
rewards without an account without a
limit so imagine that you do a certain
work and it's not going to be in the
contract ten thousand million though you
can just get unlimited you now it jumps
to a million a billion whatever
something that is our mind cannot even
comprehend as a result of these patients
because of this test you know that most
wives is given it to you so he's not
going to put something on you that's
going to break you is that right that's
right so and with every difficulty
there's common relief is that right this
is what the Prophet said the law I
seldom said as one of the ways of Allah
the more get tight that means it's going
to get spacious and ease so wait there's
another act of worship that makes things
easy that many people are not aware of
it's the worship of waiting
for the help from Allah this by itself
is meant for the human being to practice
that we are instead of waiting for the
help from Allah Allah spano time had
said about that into the messengers that
they would wait for the victory of Allah
and also on a person is hit by a
calamity and his patience and so on one
of the acts of worship to do that Allah
wants from us wait for the ease the
easel come don't worry it has to come it
won't stay miserable forever it has to
come the East has to come the words that
it can happen a person who died if he
dies on the state of a despair this is
the real spaciousness he won't want to
come back to this world anymore because
he would given the glad tidings so the
prophets are silent said do i neva and
the Quran says were in a manner Oh City
usila with tightness and difficulties
comes the ease and spaciousness so wait
for the ease it will come be patient
take a break when we write back more
here on the den show is born about 60
years ago in former Yugoslavia today's
Bosnia at the Second World War and
imagine today you have one child killed
so much it's important that we realize
that Islam is a gift so we believe that
in the teachings of Jesus what is left
there is truthfully I mean he's the
prince but the truth has been mixed up
with paganism and with nature worship
and so Islam has given you a pure
straightforward way of approaching
monotheism
longer
back here on the Dean show we're talking
with the tests of life from the womb I
said and when you're born to when you
die it's a big test in between and we
want to pass the test we want to get to
paradise we want to avoid the Hellfire
they got Almighty Allah protect us from
that now there's also a verse in the
Quran can you comment on this can these
trials and calamities also be a way for
expiating the sins that we quit we
commit daily where Allah the Almighty is
saying by your hands this is what you
produce can you comment on this right
this is and actually more than one verse
would give this meeting that nothing
would happen to you except it's because
of what your hands have burned from you
my customer ID come off wanker these
that no calamity will afflict you unless
it's because of what your hands earned
and he pardons a lot actually if a lot
of the most just deals with us with
justice we won't be existing now because
we do so many bad things but it's some
other bad things would affect us in his
life before they after so that it'll be
a way to wake us up and a lot of the
Most High forgives and forgives a lot of
the things and many of the things that
we do bad were not being punished for it
in this life to give us time and respite
so that we would repent almost panel
that but the the most biggest test ever
is as with the profits on the Lhari so
let me said that God had revealed to me
that you will be tested the same or
closer to the test of added el
Antichrist which is one of the major
signs in life when you are in your
graves you will be asked three questions
this is the final test if it's correct
to say that that if a person according
to our life and how a person passed this
test in his life he will be able to
answer these questions basically our
life is to answer these questions
practically who is your up with your
lord who was your messenger and what is
the book or what is your book the
answers is for the believers would say
my lord is Allah those who do they used
to turn to Allah alone in this life
times of calamities times of ease their
answer will
from their hearts and their messengers
prophet mohamed salah salem the one that
they followed in this life and my book
is the koban so we need to live our life
based on these three things turning to a
loss final data alone following the way
of the prophets of the law I seldom and
the Quran is our guide to our success
few more point before we come to an end
run out of time now for the person that
sees someone else on the TV on the big
screen live in a nice luxurious life and
I'm over here you know suffering and you
know I got a dime to make a phone call
can you elaborate on one hadith I
believe it is where the Prophet peace be
upon him is talking about you know the
two individuals one that has everything
the other one that does it and then this
one at the end he'll be shown the
Hellfire and he'll want to ransom it for
what he's going to be in and then the
believer a lot x peeing all his sins and
he had a touch a hard time because he
did some some some you know some sins
here and there but allah loving him he
didn't want to spend a second in the
Hellfire but then when he shown paradise
and he was like asked did you see any
hardship and he'll quickly forget can
you talk about this how do you decide is
this hadith if this is hadith and it's a
beautiful hadith that gives a very good
note at the end the hadith is more or
less the meaning that a person will come
on the day of judgment that he was the
most luxurious on the face of it and he
can imagine and let your imagination go
as far as they can and he would be among
the people of the our fangs he would be
immersed in the Hellfires one dip like
this and then he would be asked did he
had any goodness before he would say no
one la he by the name of all I never had
any goodness before but he enjoyed
everything and he enjoyed everything he
was yet a French cook for French food he
had you know Chinese cook for Chinese
for everything the most happiest person
luxurious place the other hand a person
was lived the life of misery as if he
was dragged on his face from the woman
that he was born today died imagine this
is the case of someone and he will be
among the people of Jannah paradise if
he's immersed dipped in gender paradise
just one day plug this and he would be
as did yet and he misery before he would
say no allahi by the name of all I never
had a misery before the note is what the
point is
this whole entire life that we live in
that was so much immersed in it you
would forget it all of it by just one
dip either in general paradise or may
Allah forbid a dip in now fight so is it
worth it that we would live this life
ignorant Lee that all will be forgotten
by just one immerse one dip and now fire
engine so this is we have to make
decisions and this is the the nature of
the human being that we can make
decisions knowing this and looking ahead
we're not like dogs and cats where they
see the food and they jump on it or not
knowing whether it's healthy for them or
not we have the ability to look ahead
and Allah wants us to look ahead if this
is the case and be steadfast and he
would be happy you not live a life of
misery you would live a life of
happiness contentment if you would turn
to the creator of the heavens in the
earth alone and seeking patients from it
not a manner monkey the son of the moon
but the crater of all these things the
one god that's wait and trust in him
will be successful to thank you very
much thank you very much my god almighty
credit reward you thank you sure yeah
and we got to get some more great advice
from the shade the test of life from the
womb to the tomb and drama in between
let's pass this test and God Almighty
the craters most merciful he sent
messengers through time in the last and
final messenger Jesus was sent for his
time Moses was sent for his tie a burrs
hammer sent for his time and the list
goes on but your messenger if you're
hearing this today we don't worship Him
we don't pray to him but we follow his
teaching the same way you would have
followed Jesus's teachings Abraham's to
you they were the ones teaching you how
to pray to God how to worship God how to
pass the test that God Almighty has sent
for the human beings and there is a way
and God Almighty has said whoever
chooses away other than that complete
devotion submission to the One God and
that's Islam summed up with one word the
same way of life that all the messages
of God live whoever chooses the way
other than this it will not be accepted
in the Hereafter he'll be among the
losers let's be among the winners and do
God's will not follow our desires and
let's pass the test let's be successful
let's put our trust and the one who gave
us life and he'll give us death and
we'll see you next time until that piece
you
to you he created the universe to him
alone the heavens and the earth l11 he
is the first he's the owner Murthy eat
them his messengers to all his creatures
on the great danger Oh worshiping other
than Allah there is none greater
the Creator i am not afraid to stand
alone i am not afraid to stand alone if
allies by my side i am not afraid to
stand alone i am not afraid to stand
alone if a las vacas I i am not afraid
to stay alone i am not afraid to stand
alone if a las bombas ah i am not afraid
to stay
you